our special guest today is and Wojcicki
did I pronounce that correct yes
perfect great I've been practicing all
afternoon and you grew up on campus here
I did yeah your father was a physics
professor hmm
so yes he's emeritus but he's still you
know once a professor you never stop but
I bet if you come back to campus it's
hard to recognize cuz every week there's
a new building that pops up that is true
although I I'd say come to campus almost
every week so so in that like I've been
watching the progression and it's been
pretty amazing to watch but ya know it
does definitely does not look like the
campus like we we joke that we used to
roll down Page Mill because it was all
grass and so it was like this great it's
kite hill and you could roll down it and
clearly in Sand Hill was known for the
physicists so clearly it's not anymore
oops sorry two mics yeah well we always
joke that the campus bird is the crane
so great and then you went off to Yale
where you studied biology and I would
love for you to tell us your story of
what happened from getting from being a
biology major do we need biology
managers here okay a handful of biology
man I was actually I did my PhD in
neuroscience so I'm a biologist as well
and how did you go from that to starting
23andme can you give a little bit of a
snapshot of your story sure so I I think
the real like that's the advice I give
to young people now like the reality is
whatever you think your life is gonna be
at the age of like 18 to 22 your life
will not be that and and so in some ways
like that best thing you can do is just
really push yourself to keep learning
and and I was really lucky because my
parents were people who really didn't
worry about like oh you have to find
what you want to do right away and they
like we're really supportive of you know
you should find what you're really
passionate about so so I graduate I was
a biology major I always dreamed I was
like I should so want to be a doctor
like I like I love my pediatrician I
like sick people I love medicine like I
love molecular biology I find it so
fascinating but there was something that
just didn't feel right and so I
graduated college and I was when those
people I graduated with no job plan so I
drove cross-country I was a I was in the
I need actually for a Stanford professor
John Donoghue and his wife in the law
school and my mom made me go to a job
there and in some ways like it kind of
shows how random life can be at times
but I went to this job fair and I gave
my CV to someone and they took my CV and
it ended up being for Montgomery
securities and she then knew somebody
which ended up being the Wallenberg
family in Sweden and they know there's a
bunch of Wallenberg buildings and lo and
behold they they interviewed me I only
took the job interview because I wanted
the frequent flyer miles and I was like
a good scrappy
you know Stanford brat should and and
then I took this job and like I had no
idea I didn't even know what a balance
she was like and here it was like the
Wallenberg's and like I met Marcus
Wallenberg came out to interview me and
I was like I didn't know who he was I
had to meet me at printers ink I was in
flip-flops and a skirt and I was like
you get your own bagel over there and it
was like in some ways like life is very
random and and I ended up on Wall Street
and for ten years I was investing in
healthcare companies I didn't know
anything I didn't even know what Wall
Street was but I knew that it was super
interesting and I was learning every
single day and learning about how you
know I had this passion for molecular
biology and like for me to be able to
meet with like these amazing CEOs who
are like pioneering the world and like
my first project was xenotransplantation
and I would fly around the world and
like meet with you know great academics
who are like you know trying to
understand whether or not you could
transplant animal organs into humans and
so at some point I realize like I wasn't
not that I wasn't learning but I felt
like the healthcare system was not
reflective of my values and I got into
investing and I got into you know the
whole visit cuz I was learning it was so
interesting and I love like the
potential of like oh we're all gonna
live better and it's gonna be better
healthier lives and then after a while I
started to realize that health care is
just like amazing money machine and you
know it's three trillion dollars it's
the largest part of our economy for a
reason there's so much money in
healthcare and I would have meetings
with people who were you know CEOs who
are like oh yeah you know we're seeing
margin expansion because we're really
good at collecting from the uninsured
and and you're like oh like that you
know Marge expand
it's good but like the fact that you're
like squeezing poor people like doesn't
sound great and and so I just felt like
there was like this ethical debate for
me and so in some ways 23andme came out
of this frustration that like I saw that
you know the health care system was not
reflective of me and I spent probably a
year just shorting stocks like you know
you and your anger like I was like I'm
just gonna short everything everything
fails it all sucks and and I sat with
this one professor and we were talking
about you know is obviously at the early
days of Google and that was on my mind
and has heard this discussion like well
what if you just had the world's health
information what could you do
he's like we could solve everything I
was like well then we should do that and
and it was the beginnings of the social
networks and you know crowdsourcing and
you know MySpace and and was this idea
well what if like everyone like we all
have a common interest in our health
like you look at LIVESTRONG and Susan G
Komen all these groups like people come
together and they care so like why don't
we just all come together with our
health information I don't need farman I
don't really need all the specific
academics like we can crowdsource the
world's largest study and empower each
of us with our information like let the
people rise and why is it that your
health care system is like why are they
all telling you what you want no one
ever asks you and so like 23 we came out
of a rebellion and in some ways like
we've always meant to be a rebellious
brand it was always about like I want to
change the whole system and the beauty
of Silicon Valley is that you can be
totally unrealistic with your
expectations of what you can do and and
I really believe like I tell people my
company all the time I'm like we really
can topple a three trillion dollar
industry like it's gonna be amazing like
little ole 23andme but like that's what
we're trying to do like start a
revolution and so you know 23 we came
out of that sense of like we're super
for I was super frustrated with the
industry I was very clear seeing that
the consumer has no power that there's a
potential for crowdsourcing and I was
fortunate to have sort of you know the
Stanford upbringing in this Silicon
Valley community that was really
supportive of like think crazy thoughts
and like follow your passions and it's
ok to fail
like everyone fails at different times
like do it and I think that you know
then became 23 me I love this I loved
your passion and this is such a fabulous
story first of all about the serendipity
but also how once you found your passion
you dug in deep now 23andme was such an
early early player in this game I
remember when it started and this was
sort of in this grey market you know
there were the regulations weren't there
yet maybe even the science hadn't quite
caught up with what you were trying to
do the market certainly wasn't there
which was most difficult and how has
that changed over time the technology
the market and the regulations so the
thing that has changed the least
ironically is the technology we're
actually still using the same platform
one of the things that happen when I was
you know when we were looking at
starting the company is I was I would do
calls with experts and I called somebody
at the brode and and I remember him
saying he's like you understand he's
like the enthusiasm we felt in 1999 like
we feel it again like the whole world's
gonna change and it was because alpha
metrics had introduced this whole genome
chip and suddenly you could get like all
this genetic data and was somewhat
affordable is like $1,000 a chip and he
was like it was so cool he's like we're
like kids in a candy store it's like the
potential is all there and so that in
some ways like hearing that enthusiasm
the potential that to me was a sign like
we should start the company now because
like it's cheap enough and you can
really get all this information so the
technology is the one thing I'm really
grateful for like it's Illumina has an
amazing product it is reliable it works
they drive the cost down it just gets
cheaper and cheaper but we're on the
same platform that we started with the
regulation in some ways the regulation
in the consumer market those are two
things it's almost like I was lucky from
the investing world I learned like
Amazon back in 1998 we used to have
these discussions all the time like will
consumers really put their credit cards
online and in some ways like that seems
so crazy now but that was the discussion
like we would debate it like will they
change their behaviors people want to
see a good how would you buy something
online
and so I in some ways I had this support
like when 23 me launched the consumer
was not ready and into this day after 11
years you know the consumer is now
starting to get it
but people have no idea why you would
want your genetic information and our
our society trainings people in that
cuts are coming a sense of like you
should wait for Big Brother to like tell
you what to do like if it's important
then your doctor will tell you what to
do so we've been in and it's one of the
things I've learned like if you're
changing society and how people think
and how they work you have to have
patience and so it's part of it is that
you can't do a marketing study and I
can't go and like have you know you know
marketing go out there trying to figure
out like what do people really want they
don't even know what they want like we
have to try and fail and try and fail
and like and I can see in my mind this
world of like consumer driven affordable
health care and and so we have to sort
of create that the so we have to teach
the consumer so the the regulatory side
when we launched we believed like really
simply I own myself like it's my body
and my genome is just the digital
representation of me and so like of
course I can get access to it like why
would I not be able to that seems crazy
like why would there be any prohibition
and then my taxpayer dollars go to all
this genetics research so why wouldn't I
be able to get access to that like all I
want to do is connect my my my own body
my genome and like understand what's
happening with all this research and
like I already paid for that research
like I want to see what it is so the
idea was like we're not interpreting it
like we're just we're connecting the
dots for you and I'm sorry I was like
cold mm-hmm and so we just felt like it
was it was information it was almost
like this is your First Amendment right
like you couldn't see and from a lab
perspective we felt like we fell under
CLIA which is the clinical laboratory
information act managed by a Medicare as
a laboratory developed tests and so you
know we you
lots of blood - like blood test today
and most genetic tests are all LD T's so
we felt like we were under that pathway
clearly like one of the things that's
interesting for me is like especially
from an academic perspective the history
of medicine is so interesting and you
know birth control tests used to be
super controversial in any time the
consumers at the point of interaction
like it's a director because that's
really controversial so we realize like
that we were just getting inside like
there's a lot of controversy around us
because of the direct-to-consumer and so
we did have sort of what's now known as
the most well read ever warning letter
by the FDA's history which I actually in
some ways I'm really proud of like I
think that that was a sign that we're
like doing something really different it
was sort of radical like it's the change
that we want and our approach to has
been to work with the agency and say you
know what like trying to fight with the
agency or like sort of that arrogance of
like well we'll show you like part of is
that you to really drive change you have
to change the system and so for me the
best thing that we've done is then
partner it's the partner is not the
right word but that we actually list it
like we listen to the FDA and we said
we're going to do all the things that
you asked us to do and we're gonna get a
direct-to-consumer approval for our
tests okay this all sounds great mm-hmm
and this I'm I'm all in but there have
to be some interesting ethical
considerations here I mean once you give
people this information first of all the
question of what do you do with it
you've mentioned several times you know
essentially this data is also going into
some central place and being used for
research so there's who owns that data
and do you own the data and also then
what happens with people get information
that they don't actually maybe it's not
actionable maybe they get things that
scare them you know what do you think
about from an ethics perspective yeah so
we as Hank really here hahaha
no he's on math campus he's across
campus but you know him yeah so Hank
Hank is a stanford ephesus it was funny
because like in the early days we
recognized there was gonna be all these
ethical issues and we could get an
emphasis to work with us and you know in
some ways like ephesus were like
no this is like groundbreaking like
we're gonna just you know comment you
know from afar and and it's true like
there's been a lot of really interesting
sort of ethical questions that have come
out of this my approach to it has been
sort of like there's a reality there's
like truth that comes with your DNA like
I can tell you whether or not you are
related to your family members and so
the same way it's not fun to get a
cancer diagnosis and there's no easy way
to couch that like sometimes you just
help people like or we make the data
obvious like you're not related to your
father and is there an ethical debate
about whether or not you should rush and
do that like I'm just a big believer
that that was consumer choice and I feel
like there's there's truth about you
that you should just be empowered to
learn that about you there's really
interesting ethical debates and that
like you share DNA with all of us you
should a new me you shared DNA with your
whole family and so you might want to
learn something but your sister might
not and so how do you like you might
learn that you are a carrier for the
braket mutation and your mother learns
that she's a carrier for the bracha
mutation and now your sister knows she
has a risk factor but she didn't want to
know so I've just kind of put that all
in the bucket like you have a choice to
learn about yourself the same way like
you have the right to ask about a family
history you have the ability to learn
other things about like go and get a
test on your own so the reality is like
we all share DNA in common but we're
about empowering you and there's
definitely considerations that I need to
empower you with so that when you are
getting this genetic information that
you are aware and we spent over a year
with Hank and others on the consent form
you know making sure that we were you
know as thorough as possible helping
think through what are all the different
things that couldn't you come about with
it and I would say after 11 years of
doing this the number one thing that is
with it is with family is you know you
might not want to know something but
your sibling does or you find out that
you're not related to you know there's a
lot of Secrets I went to the grave
that's suddenly on our on earth and you
realize like oh Uncle Joe is actually
just Joe and
so there's all kinds of things like that
that people start to people start to
learn and and we've always just kind of
that approach they're like the best way
to do is just to be really candid and I
think we have a brand that is very
direct and very honest and and is what
I've always said when I worked in
hospitals like there's no easy way to
tell someone you have stage 4 cancer or
like the best thing you can do is be
sort of you know factual and then help
make those decisions and for me the what
we try to do is be very like give people
the information and then create a
community around it so people can start
to understand what to do but let's just
talk about privacy there right because
now the information is out there it
exists in the world who owns it and the
consequences for me might be one one
thing but if the insurance company knows
or if the government knows or my
employer knows there might be some
interesting consequences that are
unintended can you talk about that so we
do everything we can right now to
protect your privacy um the reality is
like I'd love to see your genome sure
it's wonderful and beautiful but the
part of the reality is that your bank
account is a lot more interesting and
the banking so when I think about people
like the desire to hack in and see like
oh you know you might have blue eyes or
you know you might be the hot in those
saline like like you might have a high
risk factor for Alzheimer's it's just
not such a motivation to hack in and it
gets back to you in some ways some of
the ethical questions is that it's
potentially more within a family even
the insurance companies like when we
talk about insurance like one right now
we we will never give your information
out without specific individual level
consent but in insert we have the
question will insurance companies hack
in I'm like well you know it would be
unusual for an insurance coming to like
break a law to try to get information
about a risk factor that they don't
really have any great models built
around and plus we also have this thing
we don't have legal chain of custody on
our customers so meaning that if you
ordered five kits I have no idea if you
ever spat so from a price
see perspective like I don't actually
know that you are you like I didn't
actually see you spit it could have been
you know your five friends spat it just
went to your address and so I don't
actually have a legal chain of custody
on my customers so I think that actually
gives a fair amount of you know like I
said we do everything we can to protect
the privacy of customers but again we
spend a lot of time with privacy experts
and it was really ingrained in me that
or hammered into me that privacy doesn't
mean not sharing and that privacy
actually means choice and that people
say like I want you have the choice to
say no one sees my data or I want to
have the choice to say all my family
sees my data or make it public that we
want to enable choice and we need to do
everything we can to respect your choice
I don't want to share it with anyone and
we need to respect that but I also need
to respect your choice is saying I want
to share it with my whole family
and so we've enabled those kinds of
sharing abilities with all of our
customers in terms of the research we do
consent we ask our customers if they
want to consent for research so it's an
opt-in over 85 percent of our customers
today are in fact opting in and what we
find is similar to this sort of goodwill
nature of Susan G Komen like people want
to people want to help you know there's
no such thing as a healthy person like
everyone has something everyone has
allergies or migraines or I of
Hashimoto's like everyone has something
and so we all want to help each other
and we can all be empathetic to this
fact that like you know like my you know
one of my good friends has cancer like
I'm like everyone has a story everyone
has a friend who has something you've
all seen other people suffer and we want
to help so so the consent for us is like
it's an opt-in we ask people then to
take questions if you want but it's
always that ability you have the ability
to say I don't want to take this set of
questions or I want to withdraw my
consent
so everything for us is again it goes
back to that definition of privacy it's
like it's about choice and so if you
want to participate and take every
single survey question we have do it and
then we will tell you what you
participated in if you don't want to
then don't do it so do you consider
self a biology company or a data company
data data company so what do you do with
all this data I mean yeah I'm gonna
guess you have how many data scientists
do you have working with you it's my
head of people okay well I think it's
probably it's a fair amount I mean we
have over a hundred phd's we're over a
third sort of phd's sorry I hate to bug
some but I just have to get more water
yeah I'm just gonna I'm gonna go through
that just wait
super so great
hi great hi Pam hey sorry I don't want
to start coughing like crazy so we have
I mean what we do like we see ourselves
as a data company and I think especially
speaking to this kind of crowd you know
the the whole new world is about how do
you use data like we see what Google can
do we see what Facebook can do we see
what you know Netflix and Amazon like
all these things are based on data of
customers and so in some ways I look at
this as a tragedy that the most
important thing is not like what movie
you really want which is very important
but but when you go to the doctor use
your data to tell me what's likely to
happen to me like I find it crazy that
we have this mentality where we we
absolutely accept you know you're
diagnosed with something like my friend
diagnosed with cancer let me go and get
five different opinions because there's
not consensus like we don't actually
have the data to know what is the right
thing to do and so what we want to do is
like use our data to really transform
healthcare and so we have I see us as
like we're data company the first thing
we started doing was publishing we have
over 80 publications we try to
collaborate with as many different
academic and pharma groups as we can
because we feel like your data is really
valuable for you but like like in it's
valuable for one study but you could
participate potentially in a hundred
studies and our customers we've actually
seen that the average customer has
participated over 200 different research
projects so we're really about trying to
empower people to participate more and
more research so when the next things
that we do with data is we hired Richard
Scheller who used to be at Stanford yes
in that chair oh did a years ago yeah at
this talk yeah oh did he what he was a
genetic yeah exactly so cute Richard so
we hired he was my professor when I was
a student oh really yeah Richard which
is a lot of fun he tortures me all the
time mmm so one of the things I like
also really frustrating me on when I was
on Wall Street is that we have this
horribly inefficient drug discovery
process it's potentially the only group
I know that actively promotes how they
get worse every year like I mean I was
like when I started investing it was
seven hundred million to make a drug and
now it's two billion dollars to make a
drug like it's crazy like it's crazy
that I mean this is where it reminds me
of the Communist era of like where you
actively promote like how much you are
worse every single year so something is
wrong in this system like we like like
the whole approach the Mossad like the
mythology like something's wrong so my
hope is that if we actually started with
a giant human data set and you're
getting insights from humans instead of
potentially animals would you actually
have a higher likelihood of success and
I think that's where we've actually like
I don't have the ability to say yes yet
but my hope that is in 10 years I'll be
able to say hey by starting with a
massive massive human genetic database I
was able to develop drugs faster better
and cheaper with higher outcomes than
the rest of the industry and so that is
like one of the main things we're trying
to do with this data is like how do we
actually develop insights in our biology
and then turn that into potentially
therapeutic like we published papers and
then also develop therapeutics and one
the other things I'm also frankly most
passionate about is that no one really
pays for prevention studies so like the
whole question yours that your neuro
neurobiology like they're all just so
like how do you prevent Alzheimer's you
know whose if we actually really figure
out how to prevent Alzheimer's like
who's gonna make money on that know what
so the question there was like who's
gonna fund that study and that's kind of
the reality is like we're all of like
every single one of us in the room
cares about preventing Alzheimer's but
if I had a whole group of Pharma execs
not that they're bad but like no one's
gonna make money off for prevention
unless it's a pill and so that's what
I'm really passionate about like are
their lifestyle interventions is it food
is it diet like what is that we can do
so I think that's where that's what I
think there's like for lost my train of
thought on that one
nobody's okay that's okay but did you
actually say that you want to get into
the business of actually developing
therapies or are you just partnering
with companies that do that giving them
using your data and your oh no we're
developing drugs you are yeah we are
development like people it's funny
because I meet people sometimes I'm like
no we we hired Richard Scheller who
spent you know 15 years at Stanford and
15 years at Genentech something like
that and we we we hired him specific was
like it we want to develop drugs so we
currently have seven therapeutic
compounds or seven targets under
development and we got the question all
the time where people like well did you
buy them I'm like no no they came from
the data like well did you acquire it
I'm like no again came from the data
like it's literally it's all from our
data and so we've developed this whole
pipeline of our data sight like we we
are my consumer team we bring customers
in we ask questions we have a whole SERP
you know team of PhDs and survey
methodology who figure out how to ask
questions in the right way we analyze
the data and then we work with Richard's
whole team about how do I translate all
these insights into potentially drug
targets so can even example and and and
of that pathway because that's super
interesting
it is super interesting where did you
start what kind of insights you got and
and what sort of therapy are you
developing so the thing that's
interesting about what we have done is
that we don't do phenotype specific
research for instance I don't say I'm
gonna go find people with Alzheimer's
and I'm going to do a study on
Alzheimer's like I take everyone like
every single person in this room is
interesting to me and all of you have
something to contribute so we we follow
the data and it's in some ways like it's
it's really hard for people to grasp
that like we have you know compounds in
all kinds of it
after asthma autoimmune and we pick
those compounds or we pick those ideas
because that is where the data was most
interesting and we look at the whole
story where we can do a genome-wide
Association study and then we can like
looking to see is this genetic variant
associate with these diseases and then
we can look at Oh at this genetic
mutation people with that mutation what
are all the different conditions they
have so we can do all kinds of
interesting you know analyses of the
data that we have and we're using that
then to develop these compounds but we
don't start with a specific hypothesis
and in some ways like when we started
the company that was one of the most
controversial parts like I would meet
with scientists and they would say oh
this is a fishing expedition and get
enough data that you can find anything
and and I think that's where in some
ways for me not having a PhD or an MD
was helpful because you can think like I
wasn't trained in a certain specific way
I just have this idea like a lot of data
sounds good and and so and we've been
able to show now that like a lot of data
especially like when it is collected and
I have this appreciation now for the
survey methodology team data that's
collected well analyzing the right way
we really can get a lot of really
fascinating insights in a few minutes
questions from the audience so think
about your burning questions about the
industry the company and anything else
you have I'm curious let's let's zoom
out to the whole industry because things
the the technology is changing so fast
in so many different disciplines what
are you most excited about in this area
of healthcare and and Prevention and
genomics hmm I'm excited about us and we
are - I'm excited
um what I what I enjoy it like I think
Silicon Valley is really like so I'm
like there's like we have such a culture
there's brilliant people all over the
world but the thing that's really unique
about Silicon Valley is we have a
culture of risk and innovation and and
it just it helpful because like that
that becomes infectious like people are
like it's okay
fail it's okay to start a company and
fail and it's not that okay it's not
okay in all areas so what I enjoy is
there's really smart people who have
been through sort of the startup culture
and have done really successful
companies and they hit their 40s and
they start to get sick or they know
people who get sick and so suddenly they
they become aware of health and there's
really good enthusiasm right now from
people who I believe are willing to take
risk and really willing to know how to
innovate and build companies who are
trying to build companies for sort of
like the next generation of health care
and and I'm optimistic like I'm really
optimistic about 23 me being able to
partner with a number of these groups
that can really be able to quickly get
you data so like some of them that I
find fascinating like the ability to
look at all your radiology and can you
scan it like is their machine learning
that can potentially help scan that in a
much better way to me that's super
interesting
there's Cummings like Grand Rounds where
you can get you know expert opinions
online I'm really excited about so I'm
excited about all this sort of like this
health 2.0 world and and what's
happening and the enthusiasm from
Silicon Valley going into that I'm also
really excited and I think this is odd a
lot of people don't get this
this sequence 23 me has almost no
partnerships with with hospitals like we
have no partnership with Stanford almost
we have one partnership with in Nevada
with renown but I have a partnership
with every single retail group so Target
Walmart CVS Sam's Club and I look at
that because like the future of
prevention is not with your doctor but
the future prevention is with Walmart
and the reality is like you your health
in the status of you today is
accumulation of what you have done every
single day so I tell my kids all the
time like every single day you're making
decisions that are cumulative and they
impact your health so like if you want
to prevent disease you need to take
responsibility on a daily basis and
where do you live out your daily basis
like it might not be in this room but
the MS most of the country lives it out
at Walmart the average person goes there
three times a week so if I want to drive
real change
in this country I need to work with
Walmart and I need to be where people
are going and the reality is like no one
wants to go and hang out in the doctor
for fun
like like that's not like I don't happen
to like randomly stroll by like Welsh
Road and like see my doctor like it's
not near I mean it's near Stanford
Shopping Center but it's like not part
of my ecosystem and so that's for me one
of the big things like I think retail is
going to become really interesting as
they partner with healthcare and I think
that's going to become more and more of
an ecosystem for us to actually get a
lot of our care
so it's interesting because it's really
really interesting inside and I think
that'll be fascinating to see that play
out genetics is only one thing you can
look at right there are lots of other
things in our systems that aren't
necessarily embedded in our genome it
might be in our blood it might be in
other bodily fluids you know are you
thinking about going in that direction
as well looking at other people measure
other things we so we choking out like
we always want more more data so we have
this debate in house almost for 10 years
now about two hot topics the microbiome
and telomeres so the challenge here is
like like when I talk about genetics and
the technology I have like my technology
platform is spectacular like I can't
like I'm so grateful to Illumina that
they have this great platform that's
incredibly you know reliable and robust
and I know that when I give you a result
I feel good with those results
microbiome I don't quite have that yet
there's a lot of debate and collection
like I mean the the discussions and like
my research team they love the debate
like do I need the entire sample or do I
need part of the sample and what part
like I mean the debate is like it's kind
of fascinating and and so I just don't
think it's quite yet there there's other
stuff methylate like there's there's a
whole other world of other technologies
that I think would be interesting
the thing that I'm actually most
interested in and again it goes with
some of the prevention work and somewhat
of our rebellious brand and even just my
spirit like I'm really and also being in
Silicon Valley where people like talk
about organic and
our thali it's really good for you are
they bad for you I would love to do
environmental testing and I did in 2008
I did a test called the body burden
study where I was tested for 80
different chemicals and it was really
interesting that I was like super high
in fire retardants and it was
Environmental Working Group who did it
and they're like oh you must fly a lot
in coach and I was like I do and they're
like yeah that's circulated air and
fabric seats you absorb more than in
leather seats and so I was like oh
that's great
so yeah so it was real and I was really
high also in mercury so I stopped so it
did a couple things like one I changed
out all of our furniture to get rid of
the fire retardants I stopped eating
tuna but it was really interesting to
just know that that was in my body and I
think there was a huge potential for
23andme to have like to bring truth to a
lot of these hypotheses like like
there's we all know like it's all
there's data out there to speculate like
Oh some of these chemicals are bad but
we don't really have data to say exactly
how bad or are they really bad in our
lifestyle like they might be horrible
and rats at 150 times our concentration
but like I don't know what does that
mean for us so I would love to actually
bring truth to like some of these
questions that are out there like or
some of these like is it a hypothesis or
like some of the stuff that's about our
you know like what we do every day and
can we actually bring some real science
to that very cool who wants the first
question I have a preference for
students if you're a student doing these
students gonna raise my hand though
there you go there you go the transition
for I'm going to undergrad to whatever
you are doing right now and then later
on we talk about keeps up how do you
manage family
and being able to invest 10 years of
your life on the same project so I'm
gonna repeat the question for the
audience it essentially is okay you're
working really hard how do you balance
your work and your family yeah so I'm
lucky because my sister my sister's life
is more crazy than mine because I have
two kids and she is five and we both run
companies and her company is even bigger
so I think the thing is like it's like
one of the lessons you have as a company
is that you have to like our product
success depends on our prioritization
and my my life also depends on my
prioritization and so there's some rules
I've had like I I stopped traveling for
conferences like there's kind of a crazy
conference world you can go to endless
conferences I only do stuff that's local
or people can come in my office now like
it's just it's otherwise it's such a
suck at I'm dinner meetings are also
usually a total waste of time because
you I mean it's the reality is like
people usually want something from you
and that you can just like ask in 15
minutes and then then you're done
and so I'm really kind of strict like I
have to pry it like my kids want me like
they want me around and so I have to be
really disciplined about it and the
thing that's been hardest for me is I
love like when I first moved to New York
I have this mantra I was like I'm gonna
do everything every opportunity that
comes my way I'm gonna do it and it's
really hard now because I must get a
handful of invites every day and it's
not in my nature to say no in everything
I'm also like the Energizer Bunny like
everything looks fun and I can see the
potential and everything I'm like well I
don't know you know baby going to Sweden
and winter is fun and like it sounds
really interesting and so I've had to
learn and my team has been really
helpful with me of like saying like no
like no more travel for you like Sweden
and the winners not good and so so I
think you have to just be super
disciplined with it and and recognize
like there's some things that are fun
and something that are not being like
running a company the most important
thing like my company is also my child
and so for CEOs who are traveling all
the time you're missing like it's not
functioning well then
like you need to actually be there I
need to meet with people and I need to
spend time with my kids so it's just
about like you got a run at strict great
you have another question back there
the first question is down the line when
and you know if you're doing this very
become successful do you have any plans
to provide recompense to the patients
whose genetic data went into discovery
that drug so let's let's just say that
first you've had to essentially give
some sort of compensation to those
patients to the people who contributed
data to if there were some drugs that
came out of it and the second question
what was the process is starting such a
capital intensive business like for you
in terms of raising money did you find
it more challenging okay so the question
is you know the challenges of starting
are a capital intensive business right
so there the first one first um so I
think a lot about that like I I'm
frankly like kind of disgusted the way
the research environment today treats
participants like you're called a human
subject like at what point in time do
you ever want to be a subject like it's
just it sounds horrible and and I think
there's kind of this mentality of like
I'm gonna get you to consent I'm gonna
take everything I can from you and then
I'm out and and I just like I I just
like it's it's so dirty like it's and so
23 me is like totally built around your
a partner if you don't like what we're
doing you're gonna delete your data and
that's gonna screw us like we have
totally set this up to be a balance like
I feel compelled every time you answer a
question and then there's a publication
I need to give you that data back so I
don't know what it is like Richard and I
sort of talk about this like like we
have to do something to for the
people who are participated in some way
there's a long like we have some studies
like our our depression study was
400,000 plus individuals who participate
in that study
so there's insights from there but then
there's gonna be 10 years of work to do
so I don't I don't know what the right
plan is in some ways for people and I
hear it's all time if you're a severely
depressed individual and you participate
in this study and then we discover
something and I come back and I'm like
I'm gonna give you $15 for like what
you've done like it's insulting and even
for people who have a terminal illness
it's not about the money they're not
doing it for the money like they're
doing it for the respect and that they
want to move it forward so I think
there's things that we should do we
recruit from our our the 23andme
community all the time for studies and
so I should definitely if I recruited
you for a study like a phase 2 trial
should I do something special so you
don't have to pay for drugs or something
like that without a doubt like there's
things like that we should do I just
think it's in and I and I don't know
what it is but our approach is always
like I don't know but we should do the
right thing and whatever it is today is
not the right thing and so we're gonna
definitely innovate on it we were
totally naive you can never start a
business saying like oh I need hundreds
of millions of dollars you know we were
totally naive with like what it is and
like the beauty of being early is like
you're just naive and like the reality
of venture capitalist so you like seen
it before so they know you're naive I
mean we started a business knowing that
you know we outsource as much as we
could so like our capital really went to
just hiring people and in some ways like
we had built a plan where I was like all
the really expensive things we've
outsourced even now we just did a big
fundraiser we raised two and fifty
million dollars but that was because I
have this machine that's built and that
money is gonna go for potential funding
Rd with Richards team on the
therapeutics and a lot for marketing and
for potentially acquisitions so we
didn't need the capital
other questions there you go yeah I
wondered if there was a plan for like
collective and preventive measures maybe
using additional data sources like
smartwatches and then you could start to
so the question is are you think he's
using other sorts of data such as
smartwatches to augment the data you're
getting from your existing tests we
would love we're not doing it yet but we
would love to start doing them so you
can Matt like we will that's the kind of
data source like it's relatively
reliable and so I would love to start
actually getting you know move like I
think about movement and sleep like
those are some of the best diet is
really hard to get but movement and
sleep would be great better lifestyle
changes and lots of lifestyle changes
come the pressure positive pressure from
a community so if you go to act a friend
you go to the gym with your friends if
you have friends and eat hamburgers you
eat hamburgers you know building a good
community of users that contribute their
data is are there any plans to build a
more active community of you know people
that are interested in exercising more
or eating better cooking recipes you can
leverage that community in some way so
the question is are you interested in
leveraging the community to change
better life choices I think we want to
leverage community when it's really
targeted towards something that's
genetic or something that like it's a
real insight in you so for instance
saying like you're higher risk for
Alzheimer's and you know these are
people in their 30s high risk for
Alzheimer's community of them like what
what are like we potentially would
engage individuals to say let's do a
lifestyle intervention study and see if
we can change outcomes we have community
that we have forms right now on the site
I think that that
an example of Tedeschi where we would
partner with groups if we felt like
someone else was gonna do that better
than us like if you really want to start
to exercise better or lose weight
there's so many other people who really
are experts in that and how was the
right way than we could connect you so
we look at a lot of what our communities
and our partnerships it should revolve
in some way based on something that's
really personalized to you and I'll II
deal your genome so I think our like we
think about communities in that and like
in some ways like we're such a unique
company it's there's everyone talks
about to diet and weight loss but if I
have for instance like very specific
recommendations for you and then there's
a group of people and they're pulling in
information there that 100% I can
envision a world doing and we are
specifically starting to do a bunch of
wellness studies so it would be sort of
the diet and exercise like what is it
like you know is there a certain diet
that's better for you then you know
other people in this room and so then
you could imagine specific communities
they're great yes thank you so much for
my question concerns what happens when
all this data is crunched so I think
it's really cool that 23andme right now
feels like making drugs using this data
but down the line as you said I think
it's really interesting that like
theoretically the genome is like has
infinite power because it can find out
like everything about like what gene
control what things so what could this
pave the way towards like intelligent
design and like my question is more like
what happens to the people who can't
afford to have 23andme now especially if
at least the things like intelligent
design where we can make like designer
babies as a result of this data because
you know people who can pay for this
they can like use their data and figure
out what genes they can change you know
and like improve future generations
because idea reticle ease look possible
yeah down the line I think I think the
primary question is how are you doing
people who can't afford it who would
benefit tremendously from having this
information yeah so sorry so all answers
to aspect like people who can't afford
it we do a number of programs trying to
enable access so we'd give away a lot of
kits for free we try it like everything
we can like right now we have an offer
it's you know two
it's for $99 so $49 so we're doing as
much as we can to drive down affordable
price the second part in terms of like
intelligent design and and and whatnot I
think there's a Gattaca world that is
more science fiction than the reality so
we knit like we know CRISPR
I know cystic fibrosis but I can't cure
people yet with cystic fibrosis so
there's a long world before I'm gonna
like have a you know you know you
imagine a society of like everyone's
choosing this one Phoenix set of
phenotypes that said like I think this
is the ethical discussion like as like I
look at 23 main part of our mission like
I want to understand the genome like I
like it Keith what keeps me up at night
is like we have this code in us and we
don't understand it
how can everybody sleep like it's just
like I I really like whoa I really want
to understand like it's so interesting
in the fact that it goes back to the
beginning of time
that's so cool and so I like I want us
to be the ones who are understanding and
deciphering the genome there's all kinds
of ethical questions about CRISPR and
how are you gonna use this information
and there are realistic you know issues
like we have that need to be discussed
but I look at our job as like I want to
understand it so I want to build on that
because one of the concerns I've had
early early in the early days I was
offered to you know participate in and
get my genome done which I have not done
that yeah I did it okay well here is the
issue is I'm concerned that do we
actually really understand it enough to
be giving meaningful data am I gonna
like what the rate of knowledge in
increase of them in this world is is
super fast and we still are quite far
from really understanding it I mean
you're saying how can we sleep at night
because we don't understand it and
that's my concern is we don't understand
it and am I getting information that is
you know really accurate so there's
information we toggle in some ways like
this was a regulatory question than
somebody's like we toggled between oh my
god your data is so like so actionable
and so scary how could you give it to
people and then like oh my god you know
nothing and it's meaningless what I was
like you know pick an argument people
like either we're too scary or we're
meaningless the reality is like it's
it's it's the early days it's like we
know cystic fibrosis mutations and I
know bracha mutations and I know you
know like you know some of the familiar
hypokalemia mutations like there are
certain mutations we feel really good
about there's an entire world in the
whole genome sequencing department that
makes me nervous and it's variant bus
buses so you know variants of unknown
significance so I might like I used to
give this talk that it was you know
called dilatory as me like all when I
got my whole genome like all the
different ways I should be dead but I'm
not and so you know you start to follow
my mutations like I had this mutation
and like I look and you can look in some
of the you know the genetic databases
online to be like wow there's like all
these like really terrifying diseases
associated with this mutation so to me
the fact that we don't know everything
is like symbolic of life like we don't
know everything about everything like
it's like but it doesn't mean we
shouldn't have it like to me it's like
the the journey to actually starting to
understand what the genome means is only
gonna come by starting to actually
explore it and I really I really have
this belief like everyone can be a
scientist my dad like my number one take
away from the particle physicists is
that in in night-in in 1991-1992
my dad ran something called the
superconducting supercollider and it got
shut down by the government and it was
gonna be the largest you know giant
accelerator smasher ever and part of the
reason why I got shut down is because
the physicist couldn't articulate what
the value proposition was and all the
scientists like I repeat all the time
you hurt yourself by wearing the white
coat and using big words and talking
down to people of course the average
population believes more and Gweneth
Paltrow than they do at any one Stanford
because she speaks their language and
it's like it drives me crazy like we
have to empower people be like you know
what be honest we don't understand most
the genome but you can all still
understand it
it's beautiful and it's fascinating and
the whole journey of science is the fact
that we don't know that is what inspires
all of us to be scientists is like to
figure it out it's like there's nothing
better like my two great moments are
like the birth of my children and like
the results of an experiment did it work
like same thing with my children did
they work but like I just think like for
me the fact that's an unknown is the
beauty of it and like we're all gonna
solve it and all of us like every single
person on this planet should be
interested in it it's about them and I
really like I really I so want
scientists to embrace this idea of like
everyone could be a scientist you don't
need a degree like we can all learn in
the more that we actually get like you
know the person stocking shelves at
Walmart to understand CRISPR and what's
happening in gravitational waves the
more we're gonna get funding the more
we're all gonna be connected with the
more we're gonna actually advance
society so I really like to me that's an
opportunity we don't know and I think
medicine and healthcare in general would
be so much better if people actually
just admit it like we just don't know
most these things we don't know most of
things of how the body works but it's
job security for all those scientists
you know and all that thrill of
discovery in front of us so it's
interesting because a tremendous number
of students at Stanford study computer
science we know that there's you know
the big sucking sound of the CF
Department as people are looking at the
opportunities there can you talk about
what you where you see you know what
sort of things do you think students
should be studying you know should every
student take a biology class just as
they take you know a computer science
class what are the things that you know
if you came out of school you go
everyone should have this type of
baseline knowledge in order to just live
a fulfilling life
I mean I'm biased so I would say
computer science is definitely like I
wish I don't have a CS background like I
wish I wish I knew more how to code I
think that biology having a basic
understanding of biology and the thing
that I think is great like the more
people understand statistics like I love
like one of the first books I gave my
kids was how to lie with statistics
just cuz I think it's such a great you
know kids always start talking about you
know numbers and my son always quotes
different stuff off the internet and
that book there's again it's like a
really short book how to lie with
statistics and it really does a great
job of just showing how numbers can be
manipulated so I really like if I like
my dream hires are people who are
computer scientists who have you know
degree also then in statistics and then
a degree also in biology I it was funny
because there was one day I was
describing I was like I'd love to hire
you someone you know who's like
anthropology computer science biology
stats and they're like oh pardis and I
was like what are you talking about
they're like pretty sabeti she's a
professor at the brode I was like what a
nerd oh and she's a rockstar to plays in
the band so there are some of these
people out there I was so surprised and
I now love this woman like I spent a lot
of time with her but like to me that's
like such a fascinating convergence of
like data you know being able to code
the biology and really understand the
numbers and anthropology anthropology
like that's to me also the beauty of
like unders like being able to relate to
people and understanding the story
that's behind it like that's the most
interesting aspect for me of your genome
is like the story like why do you have
these mutations like I kind of love like
people you know lost their dark skin for
a reason you know like you wanted to
absorb more Sun inside like there's all
community I want to show is like how
we're all connected to the beginning of
time and how you evolved to be you
sitting here today so look so let's go
back in time okay I'm gonna ask the last
question okay so I imagine you were
going back to being a students and
you're 20 years old what do you wish you
knew when you were 20 you know I think I
think there's a lot of things that I I
began I I think my parents like my
parents really did a great job of of
encouraging us to to take to take risk
and not being afraid of like trying to
they knew and not being afraid of
quitting like one of the hardest things
in some ways is to change so when I
think back on that moment of like when I
graduated college and like I remember
leaving you know getting the car and
leaving enjoy cross-country I think the
number one thing I would I I didn't
realize is like how every single
experience of my life was cumulative
like every every experience so long as I
continue to learn everything has become
meaningful in retrospect so I can point
back to you know my first boss Marcus
Wallenberg who then invested and you
know has been super supportive and like
every job even when it was sometimes
painful added because I was still
learning it all added to my experiences
today and I think about on like I
volunteered in Belvedere Hospital in New
York which was like kind of a traumatic
experience but those experiences like
really formed me and and I think the
thing that I like that I my parents
emphasized and that I pushed other
people on today is always quit like
leave if you're not learning and if
you're not doing something new if you
don't feel stimulated and I think that
is at that moment in time you sort of
worry as a like 30 year old like my god
my life is like so random but I think
part of it is like eventually it all
comes together
and I think it's really important to
just like the more you push yourself at
some point like there's not that
pressure of like oh you have to figure
it all out this time but at some point
the story comes together well
your curiosity your passion your drive
your enthusiasm and of course your
intelligence are incredibly inspiring
please join me in thanking
[Applause]
you